good morning and welcome back to another
episode of The Joy of mathematics I'm
Toby and today we're going to be talking
about the world of white holes you might
have heard of black holes before these
scary sinks of gravitational potential
from which nothing can escape black
holes were predicted to exist a long
time ago and then scientists eventually
found evidence that they do exist well
white holes are kind of like the
opposite of black holes they are born in
the depths of a black hole where time
dances backwards nothing can enter a
white hole but everything inside of it
will eventually be pushed out for now
white holes remain just a mathematical
prediction and we haven't detected any
but thinking about white holes helps us
to understand the physics in a deeper
way this video was inspired by Carlo
relli's latest book white holes and
thank you to Riverhead books for sending
me a copy the book doesn't try to
convince you that white holes exist
because they might not instead it talks
about what it is like to play in the
mathematical sandpit of these abstract
ideas abstract as a white hole and what
it means to think about them and to
research them rll's book will be
available wherever books are sold in the
US from the 31st of October and that
book will help you to understand these
Concepts in a deeper
way black holes are as abundant as the
stars that twinkle in the night sky in
fact many black holes are formed from
dying Stars when stars are alive they
are radiant burning hydrogen every day
is a good day when you're a star you
could imagine them singing for billions
of harmonious years but eventually they
will have a bad day their fuel is
steadily running out turning into helium
and other elements when the most
enormous Stars run out of fuel they
collapse under the irresistible pool of
gravity becoming black holes matter
isn't swallowed into Oblivion instead
it's spirals inward towards the Central
Star within the black hole there it
continues to exist even though light
from this matter cannot escape to the
outside it is enveloped in mystery held
prisoner by a gravitational
pull black holes are often portrayed
like this it's what looks like 2D flat
space warping into a funnel but this
isn't the whole picture this common
drawing is not a mistake but a happy
accident born from the need for
Simplicity given that stars are
spherical their collapsed version is
also spherical The Event Horizon the
point of no return is not a circle but
instead is a sphere if we were inside a
black hole we would find ourselves
trapped in ever smaller spheres as we
sunk deeper into its depths drawings
like this are missing a dimension to
become more accurate every Circle should
actually be a sphere the Spheres would
be overlapping on top of each other like
a Russian doll drawings like this are
more of a map of gravity as well from
the center it would require an enormous
amount of energy to climb out and since
black holes are symmetrical in all
directions this slice is okay to
represent the entire
sphere we can paint a horizon with a a
single brush stroke it signifies the
boundary of our site separating water
from Sky a ship sailing over the horizon
won't stop existing once it passes it
and the sailors wouldn't notice it's
just us onlookers back on the beach who
will think the boat has disappeared the
same is true for the Horizon of a black
hole if our friend Carlo was to travel
to a large black hole and managed to
cross the Event Horizon he wouldn't even
notice super massive black holes are
large enough that changes in gravity are
spread out and they are less likely to
hurt you it's only the small black holes
you need to worry about they could turn
you into spaghetti because gravity's
well is very steep Carlo's watch
continues ticking at its normal rate but
to us watching from the outside he would
slow to a stop past the Horizon Carlo
would disappear from our sight because
the light from him could no longer reach
us but Carlo himself would be happily
bobbing along deeper into the black hole
many textbooks condemn whoever enters a
black hole but don't worry Carlo could
come out again he just needs to find
another way out and that happens to be
via a white
hole Einstein gifted us the idea that
gravity is the Distortion of SpaceTime
where the SpaceTime grid represents
events each with a position and a time
so the gravity well of a black hole can
be represented by a f tunnel of space
time and as the black hole ages the
shape changes lengthening and growing
narrower with the passage of time we
only know this thanks to Einstein's
equations which illuminate that which
would otherwise be invisible to us
Einstein's equations do have a
limitation though they can't be used to
describe extreme conditions and for the
black hole things do get extreme as the
diameter of the funnel Narrows the
cylinder becomes more curved like a roll
is rolled Tighter and Tighter this
Distortion of SpaceTime is so severe
that Einstein's equations no longer work
luckily though quantum physics can save
us when it rains and water falls from
the sky it doesn't fall in one
Continuous Flow instead it falls in
millions of tiny individual droplets
each happy little droplet could be
called a Quant of rain where the word
Quant means the smallest unit that makes
up up a hole now let your imagination
wander to light it too can be thought of
as a shower of light drops instead of a
continuous flow these individual bundles
or quanta of light are what we are
describing with quantum physics we could
also think about splitting space itself
up into quanta if each little piece of
SpaceTime is like a grain of sand then
together they make up the beach of our
universe the inside of a black hole
cannot be squashed any further
than the size of the individual grains
of SpaceTime this is where Einstein's
equations stop working here space is
distorted on the quantum
level if I drop a ball it falls to the
ground then bounces back up in a black
hole space time is falling upon itself
so shouldn't it also be able to bounce
back when a ball bounces it's as if a
film of its fall were being played in
Reverse if we played a film of a black
hole in Reverse what would we see we
would see the star and SpaceTime
bouncing back we would see a white hole
a white hole is a black hole played
backwards in time quantum physics links
the two space times because the
transition occurs when space is squashed
Beyond its granular limit in quantum
physics things don't always have a
position they can be nowhere living in a
haze of probabilities this fact allows
particles to LEAP or tunnel through
space and Grains of space themselves
might also be able to LEAP flipping a
black hole to a white
one in a black hole you can enter but
not leave and in a white hole you can
leave but not enter anything that enters
a black hole can and dance with the
limits of space and time before passing
into a white hole and coming out again
an unsettling thought is that from the
outside we can't easily distinguish a
black hole from a white one one may
expect that with the hands of time
running backwards that the pull of
gravity would turn into a push but
that's not the case in a film of the
solar system being run backwards the sun
still pulls the planets in a cosmic
Embrace nothing can cross the Horizon
and enter a white hole but watching from
afar we never see anything cross the
Horizon and enter a black hole either to
us Carlos time would appear to slow as
he approached the Horizon of a black
hole crawling to a stop it would seem to
take an Infinity for him to cross the
Horizon and even if we stayed up late
we'd never catch
it with black and white holes appearing
the same from afar we are remed remed of
the importance of looking beyond what
can be immediately seen we might not be
correct about white holes they might not
exist at all or have properties that we
weren't anticipating one idea is that a
black hole and a white hole could be
linked forming a kind of Wormhole
between two universes or two regions of
space bridging across the fourth
dimension the scientists who have given
us these ideas have done their best to
paint accurate pictures but paintings
require a bit of creativity and in that
way scientists are artists I think
there's an artist hidden at the heart of
every one of us you too can paint
inspiring pictures so how would you
imagine the inside of a white hole
having doubts is okay that's the thrill
of science always wondering if what
you've done is correct with uncertainty
growing into new bigger
ideas Carlo relli is a physicist who has
spent much of his his life studying the
quantum aspects of space and time and
his book white holes is not just about
explaining the scientific ideas but is
also about the mind of a scientist at
work he mentions other ideas of white
holes including that the Big Bang which
created this universe of ours could have
been a white hole that was formed from a
collapsing Universe bouncing back relli
writes in a very poetic way that can
communicate the ideas physics to someone
who doesn't know much about it but also
can offer New Perspectives for someone
who knows a lot already there's a link
to order a copy of his book down in the
description thank you to Riverhead books
for sponsoring this video and thank you
for watching I hope that you have an
absolutely mathematical day thanks for
watching this video and thanks to my
patreon supporters for making it
possible a special shout out to today's
Patron cat of the day
Cassini
[Music]